[Music]
how's this dude still alive he's not a
dude
neuro dude this is a man my handsome
muscular man unless car here we are on
the set of Avengers I've been lucky
enough along with other guardians of the
galaxy to join up with the Avengers and
be here and get an opportunity to save
the world
he's my cue an Avenger now well I don't
know maybe like a third string Avenger
yeah was one of the founding members
yeah thank you so it's you know out of
all the people that I've had the good
fortune to work with these two
particular guys and the triumvirate that
we formed together
it's very special friendship and
decade-plus of time together
go team yeah
it's been this witnessing of like
people's lives growing and changing it's
been a really cool experience working
with Lizzy is been really really awesome
and I think there is something very
powerful about being able to play women
who do a row things and those women are
so awesome so we've had a really good
time
hanging out with everyone on the set is
one of the best parts of this job
actually because it does have this kind
of large extended family feel I had a
bit of a bucket is someone who I
practice I thought he'd be good fun I'm
proven completely wrong in that front he
was odd Lluis and boring and not
particularly funny
well at first Blanche it's hard to know
what to make a Cumberbatch and then the
more time I spent with him on and off
set I just kind of infatuated with this
guy I was thinking you know the journey
that Robert Downey jr. is made he's the
Godfather of all this it's literally
been the adventure of a lifetime I get a
little misty thinking about it so you
know I lucked out
[Music]
the entire time I knew him he only ever
had one call
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
danos
[Music]
we got one advantage
he's coming to us
we have a dance once so that's what we
use
[Music]
let's talk about this plan dears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good
Wow
the end is near
une undone
[Music]
half of humanity will still exist
perfectly balanced
as all things should be
I hope they remember you
[Music]
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man
[Music]